frédéric landi bonjour merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france alors le 5
août 2019 il y as exactement un an jour
pour jour le gouvernement indien révoqué
l'autonomie constitutionnelle du
cachemire indien
quel est votre regard sur la situation
dans cette région un an après cette
décision est bien évidemment la
situation ne s'est pas améliorée depuis
les parties du discours officiel du
gouvernement indien quand la décision a
été prise il ya un an c'était que une
telle décision allait amener la paix
allez habiter le développement
économique mais bien sûr on en est loin
comme ça a été dit dans le reportage
toute la région est sous une chape de
plomb
internet est réduite à la 2g c'est à
dire que même pour le traitement de la
du grenat virus il yad'énormes problèmes
et d'un point de vue géopolitique
militaire et sécuritaire la situation
est effectivement ses explosifs
concrètement aujourd'hui comment est-ce
que se manifeste la reprise du pouvoir
indien dans cette région je voudrais pas
la reprise de jus d'airelles la prise en
main du pouvoir
alors ça se traduit on l'a vu par une
armée omniprésente on parle de 500 mille
soldats dans une région qui a 14
millions d'habitants
donc c'est tout à fait énorme ça se
traduit aussi constitutionnellement par
ce qui a été évoqué dans le reportage
jusque-là en vertu de l'article 170 le
jammu et cachemire avait certains
privilèges on va dire c'est une
spécificité en tout cas tout cela est
abolie et désormais le jammu et
cachemire a été coupée en deux en deux
territoires fédéraux le ladakh d'une
part et puis les deux régions du jammu
et du cachemire territoire fédéral veut
ça ne veut pas dire forcément
suppression la démocratie locale
ça ne veut pas dire suppression
forcément d'un gouvernement élu
localement on a le cas de délit on a le
cas de pondichéry où je suis le
directeur de l'institut français entre
parenthèses je suis pas seulement
professeur à
à nanterre qui sont des territoires avec
une démocratie locale
mais vous avez d'autres territoires
fédéraux où il n'y a pas de gouvernement
où le pouvoir exécutif et thomas d'un
gouverneur nommé par new delhi espèce de
préfet si vous voulez et pour l'instant
alors même qu' il ya des provisions pour
qu'il y ait un gouvernement à terme au
jammu et cachemire
eh bien on en est loin et c'est donc le
gouverneur c'est donc le gouvernement
fédéral qui a tous les pouvoirs et les
partis politiques et les représentants
politiques locaux ont été très longtemps
emprisonnés et encore aujourd'hui mais
booba moufti qui avait été premier
ministre du jammu et cachemire chief
minister dans une coalition avec le
parti budget pic est au pouvoir
à new delhi avec le parti de narindra
maudit ll reste en détention
non pas vraiment une une mise en sous
une chape de plomb comme je l ai dit de
tout de tous les pouvoirs politiques que
locaux à l'exception donc de toutes les
émanations du gouvernement fédéral
et comment sont perçus ces événements
sur place par les habitants du cachemire
on ne sait pas très bien on le devine
bien sûr il ya beaucoup de fuites mais
la presse est muselée les réseaux
sociaux existent n'existe pas évidemment
c'est perçu extrêmement mal puisque le
l'économie est complètement gelé et les
libertés sont supprimés dans quelle
énorme rancoeur qui ne date pas d'hier
les depuis au moins les les élections
truquées de 1987
et bien il y à une guérilla des
mouvements régionalistes nationalistes
indépendantistes se sont développées au
cachemire et qui ont pris la succession
de ce qui existait lors de la création
de l'état en 1947
mais évidemment ça s'est renforcé depuis
et ce qui est peut-être nouveaux
c'est que le autant
les infiltrations venus du pakistan en
voisins pouvaient avoir un rôle certain
dans ces agitations jusque là autant il
semble bien qu aujourd'hui la frontière
est quand même bien bouclé et les
rebellions et tous et tous ces meurtres
de part et d'autre ils se font au sein
même de la population du cachemire je
veux dire par là que le jammu et
cachemire on n'a pas besoin de l'ennemi
entre guillemets pakistanais pour être
dans une situation vous parlez vous
freinez clan dit vous parlez du pakistan
aujourd'hui où en sont les tensions avec
avec ce pays autour de cette question
épineuse
oui c'est une question qui n'en finit
pas de d'enflammer les relations entre
les deux frères ennemis
c'est ça qui a créé la première guerre
dès la création des deux états en 1947
n'oubliez pas que on a là les plus vieux
casques bleus de l'onu juste après la
palestine qui se sont installés dès 1949
ça a donné lieu à deux guerres sinon
trois cette région du cachemire
donc ça a toujours été absolument énorme
problème entre les deux pays
évidemment le pakistan et si je peux
dire un peu rapide de cette aubaine
puisque ça donne ça lui donne des
arguments pour montrer que la boucle sur
le cachemire y de la région du cachemire
à dominante musulmane et sous sous la
botte du gouvernement fédéral et j'ai
envie de dire que même si actuellement
la le pakistan à essaye de mener une
campagne mondiale dans cet anniversaire
dans ce premier anniversaire pour
dénoncer l'initiative indienne j'ai
envie de dire que le pakistan tout
intérêt à laisser se gâter les choses du
côté de l'autre côté de la frontière
parce que j'ai l'impression que je
dirais que le gouvernement donne à
rennes drame odyssée un petit peu tiré
une balle dans le pied avec cette
décision qui ne qui ne fait qu'envenimer
les choses
merci frédéric landi pour toutes ces
précisions je rappelle que vous êtes
professeur de géographie à l'université
paris ouest nanterre la défense et
membre associé du centre d'études de
l'inde et de l'asie du sud merci à vous